uh i want to go over something sort of
in more detail that is really important
to understand because i'm now getting a
ton of emails about it i want to devote
its own segment to it rather than just
mentioning it as an aside and what i
want to talk about is
the bogus reporting in florida of covid
deaths
that no matter when you look it looks
like deaths are declining so rapidly in
florida things must be going super well
in florida if you look at the death
charts and florida has figured out a way
to report deaths that it always creates
a downward decline
downward decline doesn't make sense a
steep decline
um and i want to explain to you exactly
how it works there's actually an article
about this in the miami herald florida
changed its coveted data creating an
artificial decline in recent deaths and
the article explains exactly how it
works
as cases ballooned in august the florida
department of health changed the way it
reported death data to the cdc
giving the appearance of a pandemic in
decline
on monday florida death data would have
shown would have shown an average of 262
daily deaths over the previous week
under the former reporting system
instead the monday update from florida
showed just 46 new deaths per day
over the previous seven days
the dramatic difference is due to a
small change in the fine print this is
the key part until three weeks ago
data collected and published on the cdc
website counted deaths by the day they
were recorded a common method for
producing daily stats used by most
states on august 10 florida switched its
methodology and along with uh just a
handful of other states began to tally
new deaths by the date the person died
if you chart deaths by florida's new
method based on date of death it will
generally appear even during a spike
like the present that deaths are on a
recent downslope that's because it takes
time for deaths to be evaluated and
death certificates to be processed when
the deaths finally are tallied they are
then assigned to the actual date of
death creating a spike where there was a
downslope in the past this is let me
paraphrase this okay
here is what the chart of florida deaths
look like and you see
that absolutely massive downslope
what is happening is if it takes longer
than seven days for a death to show up
in the totals
it's not included in the current seven
day average so when you delay assigning
the deaths to a specific day at least a
week
when you look at the last seven days
there's almost no deaths there and that
causes this massive decline current
deaths recent deaths will always look
low because it's taking you a week or
more to assign those deaths to a date
this is
extraordinarily disingenuous and when
you look at the seven day average it
looks as though they're over the peak
they're seeing this big decline and then
on day eight
you assign the deaths to day one
they're now outside of the seven day
average you look back at that day that
said 40 deaths now it says 260 or
whatever the number was and you're
constantly pushing the spike back a week
in time
extraordinarily disingenuous this should
come as a surprise to no one who is
outside of the right wing news bubble
florida has been a disaster ron desantis
has been a disaster but what's really
wacky is
could this be a method
that helps ron desantis get reelected in
2022
one of the top 2022 races in my mind in
terms of implications for 24
is the gubernatorial race in florida not
only because ron desantis as governor in
24 is more likely to participate in the
voter hijinks etc
but also because it would be a signal
about the state of florida in terms of
how it is likely to vote the florida
gubernatorial race one of the most
important 2022 races we are going to
engage with that race we're going to get
people activated on that for sure and in
terms of people oh i'll mention that
just because we're talking about it
i've been getting emails about like when
do i think our 2022 coverage is going to
ramp up
historically
the interest in midterms starts around
march april i think it's going to be
earlier this year because of the stakes
because of the pandemic because of a lot
of different things including the fact
that this is the first referendum
november of 22 is when we will see
are was it a was it an error by voters
to elect people like marjorie taylor
green
and madison cawthorne and others
and there go and are they going to be
removed at the first opportunity which
would be next november november of 22
or is this uh movement this maga clown
movement here to stay and are we going
to see some of those people re-elected
so this is a big deal midterm and i
expect even though normally it gets
going in march april uh it's probably
going to be more like february would be
my guess
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video